In the aftermath of the disastrous Exxon Valdez
oil spill of 1989, the SCP Foundation received
a tip about some anomalous plant life surrounding
the affected area.
Plants there were beginning to mutate and
change for seemingly no reason.
With concerns about pollution on everyone’s
mind, it seemed possible that the plant life
had been directly affected by the oil spill
itself.
After all, humanity’s destructive impact
on the Earth had already become noticeable
even decades ago.
However, when the Foundation showed up to
investigate, they found something much stranger.
All of the mutated plants had a common substance
on them, in their pollen, seeds, roots, or
the surrounding soil, and we’re not talking
about the millions of gallons of spilled crude
oil.
No one had ever seen this substance before,
and all tests on it proved inconclusive.
They collected samples of it and began extensive
studies of what would become known as SCP-1100.
Though SCP-1100 was initially classified as
Safe in the Foundation records, it would quickly
reveal itself to be anything but.
The first entry in SCP-1100’s official file
described it as a complex organic substance
that causes anomalous transformations in natural
plant life.
It can be transmitted between plants by way
of pollen and seeds.
Within 72 hours, an infected plant becomes
dangerous or hostile to human life.
During testing, Foundation researchers exposed
a variety of edible plants to SCP-1100, artificially
pollinating the plants with samples of the
compound.
Tomatoes, apples, strawberries, carrots, and
cabbage were among the plants tested.
As the fruits and vegetables ripened, many
visual differences became apparent right away.
The skin of the tomatoes thickened and darkened
into an off-putting leathery brown until it
was incredibly difficult to bite through or
even slice into with a knife.
When the tomatoes were finally cut into pieces,
the flesh was coarse and dry.
The cabbage took on the appearance of rotten
food, growing a fine layer of mold as the
leaves became slick and oily.
The strawberries sprouted incredibly sharp
thorns where ordinary strawberries simply
had seeds, becoming unsafe to eat.
The carrots and apples were visibly unchanged
but had some unfortunate side effects when
fed to D-class personnel at the site.
The carrots induced nearly instantaneous vomiting
and dizziness, triggering a seizure in one
particularly unfortunate subject.
The apples, on the other hand, had developed
hard, sharp structures near the core.
Much like the classic urban legend of the
razor blade hidden in the Halloween apple,
personnel who sampled the fruit suffered lacerations
to their gums, tongue, and roof of the mouth.
Whether through disgusting appearance, tougher
skin, and thorns, or harmful side effects,
all of the plants were rendered completely
inedible.
Initial containment procedures were not terribly
strict.
SCP-1100 was kept within the Secure Biohazardous
Materials Storage unit at Bio-Containment
Site 33.
This seemed to adequately contain the substance,
until one day during a bit of routine scientific
testing.
A large amount of SCP-1100 was gathered for
experimentation, when out of nowhere it vaporized,
disappearing into the air.
Not only did it contaminate the plant life
specifically set aside for the experiment,
but it traveled through the vents and infected
all of the plant life being grown at the site.
Specifics of the incident have been redacted
from the record, but 70% of the on-site personnel
were killed in this containment breach.
In the aftermath, the remainder of SCP-1100
was moved to Bio-Containment Site 26.
The object’s class, formerly listed as “safe,”
was upgraded to “Euclid.”
After it was transferred to Site 26, experimentation
with SCP-1100 resumed.
After being exposed to the substance, this
new round of plants transformed in a variety
of ways within 48 hours, with increasingly
disturbing results.
A mango tree underwent a chemical transformation.
The fruit, previously ripe and fragrant, became
filled with highly corrosive acid.
When touched, the transformed mangos would
burst, spraying this caustic liquid all over
the person who touched them.
Long vines of common ivy developed muscle-like
internal structures.
One poor D-Class made the mistake of putting
his hand a bit too close to an infected ivy
plant, only to have it wrap around his hand
and crush the bone into powder before he could
get away.
A rose bush’s thorns elongated, hardening
and sharpening to a point comparable to a
knife.
Another rose bush excreted a toxic substance
from its thorns that, when tested, was found
to be similar to the type of neurotoxin found
in the deadly cone snail.
As these experiments continued at Site 26,
several of the researchers assigned to SCP-1100
noted that it was becoming increasingly dangerous
to contain and that its effects were becoming
stronger, more pronounced, and taking effect
much more quickly.
At this point, no source could be found for
the substance, though a theory was posited
by Dr. Smith that it was the creation of a
radical environmentalist group with access
to resources and technology on the same level
as the Foundation.
A task force was put together to monitor environmentalist
groups around the globe for possible hints
about the creator of SCP-1100.
During the course of the experiments at Site
26, SCP-1100 vaporized spontaneously again.
It spread throughout the office in record
time, wiping out 96% of the on-site personnel.
At that point, in a desperate attempt to stop
the infection from spreading to other sites
or even into the civilian world, a research
assistant made the choice to detonate the
on-site nuclear warhead.
The infection was stopped, but all remaining
surviving personnel were killed in the blast,
and the surrounding area - afflicted with
irreparable damage.
SCP-1100 was moved to a triple-redundant hermetically
sealed container, stored in a containment
chamber at an unlisted Foundation site.
The container is checked daily, to ensure
that it is still completely intact and able
to hold the substance.
If anything should happen to the container,
SCP-1100 is to be immediately transferred
to a new one.
After the devastating loss of Site 26, and
additional experimentation, SCP-1100’s class
was changed from Euclid to Keter.
This allowed the Foundation to allocate additional
resources to its containment, seeing as Safe
and Euclid containment procedures had both
resulted in catastrophic loss of human life.
And in both instances, they had been profoundly
lucky that it hadn’t been worse.
After determining that exposure to SCP-1100
would make edible plants unfit for consumption
and heighten the danger of other normally
innocuous plants, the Foundation became curious
about the effects the substance might have
on animal test subjects.
A variety of species were selected for the
animal trials, including deer, mice, cows,
chickens, cats, and dogs.
The deer and the mice, both ordinarily considered
to be docile prey animals in the wild, were
the first to be exposed to SCP-1100.
Within 24 hours, they had become much stronger
and more aggressive.
One of the deer was able to break down the
door of an observation room by ramming against
it with its head.
Once it had broken out of the room, it proceeded
to charge and attack any person that it saw.
The mice became prone to swarming researchers
and biting them wherever they could, with
jaw strength capable of biting through hazmat
suits and even biting one person’s finger
clean off.
Any attempts to subdue the animals were futile,
the creatures somehow fighting off even the
strongest sedative.
The only way to prevent the infected deer
and mice from continuing to attack was to
terminate them.
Next, the cows and chickens were exposed to
SCP-1100.
They did not display any behavioral changes
once exposed, nor did they show any increased
strength.
The cows and chickens continued to behave
normally, going about their days as if nothing
had changed.
They did not respond to the presence of humans
with the exception of feeding times, during
which they would approach only to eat their
food.
A selection of the livestock were slaughtered,
in order to perform an autopsy and look for
anomalies in their bodies.
Everything looked unchanged, until some of
the meat was prepared for consumption and
given to a selection of D-class personnel.
The beef taken from the infected cows was
impossible to digest, causing a dramatic amount
of gastric upset, cramping, and vomiting.
Testing showed that, inexplicably, it had
no identifiable nutritional value.
The chicken, on the other hand, became highly
toxic, showing lethal levels of cyanide and
arsenic naturally present in its flesh when
tested.
Like with the fruits and vegetables, exposure
to SCP-1100 made the cows and chickens impossible
for human beings to eat.
The cats and dogs were last to be experimented
on.
No matter how docile and friendly the animals
were at first, within 24 hours they had become
vicious.
At the sight of any human, they would attempt
to attack.
Like the deer and mice, they could not be
subdued by any level of sedative, displaying
shocking levels of strength and resilience
for their size.
One D-Class lost his arm, and another had
his eyes clawed out before the subjects could
be terminated.
Whatever SCP-1100 was, it made everything
it touched dangerous to humans.
Even man’s best friend could be convinced
to turn on him in only a single day.
As might be expected, given the significant
loss of life and the destruction of two different
Foundation sites, experimentation with SCP-1100
has been suspended until further notice.
The substance went from affecting plants and
animals within 72 hours to accomplishing it
in 48, and then 24.
It is becoming more efficient, and more dangerous.
If allowed to continue adapting, it could
someday transform infected organisms in only
a minute.
If the substance ever escapes containment
again, defoliants and desiccants are to be
deployed within a 1-kilometer radius of the
infected area, and the area must be quarantined
for 12 months.
If the situation becomes dire enough, nuclear
or chemical weapons may be deployed in order
to distract the public and provide an acceptable
explanation for the quarantine.
How had things gone so horribly wrong so fast?
Bits of surveillance video were recovered
from the ruins of Site 26, providing a glimpse
into what exactly happened before the entire
site was destroyed.
The footage pieced together is not entirely
conclusive, but here is what we know for sure:
A Foundation researcher referred to as Dr.
V disarmed and shot the armed guard at the
entrance to SCP-1100’s containment facility.
While he did this, another Foundation researcher
known as Dr. M entered the containment and
took the sample of SCP-1100 out.
The footage cuts out for a while here, but
it becomes clear when the video resumes that
Dr. V and Dr. M dumped part of the sample
into the Site’s water supply, and vaporized
the rest of it into the air.
This is believed to be the cause of the mass
contamination that occurred at the site, which
was previously thought to have been accidental.
Dr. V and Dr. M were later linked to an environmentalist
organization on the Foundation’s watch list.
During the investigation of Dr. V and Dr.
M, a diary was recovered from Dr. V’s home.
In it, he wrote about his personal theories
regarding SCP-1100 and where it might have
come from.
While his colleagues proposed SCP-1100 was
some sort of deliberately engineered bioweapon,
Dr. V believed it to have a far more organic
point of origin.
He stated plainly: “It’s a planetary immune
response.
It’s Gaia, Mother Earth, fighting back against
us.
The more we try to fight it, the worse it
gets.
She wants us all dead, wants us gone because
of what we’ve done to Her.
And there’s nothing we can do to stop it.”
He concluded the entry with the assertion
that the only thing humanity can do now is
accept the punishment the Earth wishes to
give us.
This was his final entry before he and Dr.
M triggered the destruction of Site 26.
Were the Doctors right?
Should we just accept that the Earth is done
with humanity, and ready to drive us to extinction
before we can do any further damage?
The jury’s still out on that.
Perhaps we can turn back the clock, mitigate
the harm done to the natural world, and attempt
to earn back its favor before it’s too late.
But if SCP-1100 ever makes its way out of
containment and reaches the plants and animals
of our world, turning them all against us
one by one, we won’t have much of a choice.
Now go check out “SCP XK Class End of the
World Scenarios Explained” and “SCP-2000
- Deus Ex Machina” for more SCPs that could
cause or prevent the end of the world as we
know it!